All right, let's get right into
it.
Today we're deconstructing a
really powerful and frankly
pretty stark strategic doctrine
for a hypothetical second Trump
term.
This all comes from a sub Stack
article, and we're going to
unpack the potent metaphors and
the step by step Planet
describes for, well,
fundamentally remaking the
state.
And yeah, right from the start,
the source material pulls no
punches.
This one quote sets the entire
tone.
The argument we're about to
explore isn't framed as, you
know, a gentle course correction
or a couple of policy tweaks.
No, it's presented as a radical
surgical procedure.
So here's our road map for this
explainer.
We'll kick things off with the
diagnosis, take a look back at
the first term, and then really
dissect the strategy for a
second one, including its main
target.
We'll get into how the
government is described as being
at war with itself before we
land on that final, pretty
dramatic conclusion.
OK, so let's start with the core
metaphor that holds this entire
strategy together.
The source frames the current
political situation not as some
problem to be managed, but as a
critical condition that requires
a really drastic intervention.
The argument being made here is
that the time for small
conservative measures is just
over.
A potential second term is
framed as that exact moment of
decision when you stop trying to
treat the symptoms and you
decide you have to cut out the
disease itself.
Now, to really get the logic
behind this proposed surgery,
the author first has to give a
diagnosis of what went wrong the
first time around, and the first
term is presented not as a
success, but as a failed
treatment that actually made the
underlying condition worse.
The imagery in this quote is
pretty vivid, The source argues
the first term was disruptive.
It was loud, it was chaotic, you
know, kicking over tables.
But it didn't fundamentally
change the power structure.
It left the choir, as they put
it, completely untouched.
And here you can really see the
proposed shift in strategy.
The first term is framed as all
improv and chaos.
The second is seen as methodical
and destructive.
The goal isn't just to make
noise anymore, it's to make sure
quote the desks are empty.
So the author presents this kind
of fool me once theory.
The first try was a revolution,
tons of energy, but no real plan
to hold the territory.
The second is envisioned as an
occupation, A deliberate,
systematic effort to actually
control the machinery of
government.
So what does this occupation
actually look like?
Well, according to the source,
this scorched earth doctrine
translates that whole surgical
metaphor into some very, very
direct administrative action.
The plan, as it's laid out, is
A4 pronged purge.
We're talking mass terminations
in key departments like the DOJ
and state, forced retirements
for career officials, cutting
loose federal contractors.
And this is a big one, zeroing
out the budgets for NGOs and
other outside groups.
But this whole purge isn't
supposed to be random.
It has a very specific
conceptual target, and the
author gives it a name, the
intercom.
It's presented as the central
nervous system of the
opposition.
OK, So what is the intercom?
Well, as the source defines it,
it's this huge interconnected
web of institutions, think
nonprofits, media outlets, even
parts of the government itself,
that are all seen as working
together to promote a single
ideology, often with taxpayer
money.
And dismantling it means taking
these very practical steps.
It's all about, in the author's
words, cutting off the oxygen.
That means defunding everything
from foreign aid and public
media to cultural programs and
advocacy groups that are
perceived to be part of this
network.
So this strategy leads to a
scenario the author describes as
absurdist theater, a government
that looks like it's openly
fighting with itself.
And the source uses a really
specific anecdote to illustrate
this whole paradox.
So let's look at this key study.
It all centers on one government
employee whose actions are
presented as a symbol of this
very internal conflict.
I mean, this sequence of events
described here is pretty
extraordinary.
You have a DOJ lawyer protesting
his own administration,
confronting federal agents, and
then being charged and fired by
the very department that employs
him.
It's literally the state acting
against itself.
And this quote, just, it
captures the essence of it
perfectly.
The Aurora Boris, right?
That ancient symbol of a snake
eating its own tail.
It's being used here to describe
a government that has turned
inward, attacking and labeling
itself in this endless cycle of
internal conflict.
So what's the justification for
a purge like this?
Well, from the perspective laid
out in the article, individuals
like Sean Dunn aren't seen as
dissenters.
They're seen as moles, agents
working inside the government to
subvert it from within.
And all of this brings us full
circle, right back to that
initial stark medical metaphor
and the ultimate reason for such
a radical approach.
After laying out the diagnosis,
the failed first attempt, and
the scorched earth tactics, the
source gets to the final
question.
Why?
Why go to such extremes?
What's the end goal here?
The answer provided is
unflinching.
The whole procedure is described
as surgery with no anesthesia.
The justification is all about
speed and decisiveness to
perform the amputation so
quickly that the system just
doesn't have time to react.
And what's really essential to
understand is that from the
viewpoint being described, this
isn't some new war.
It's framed simply as finishing
a job that was started but left
undone during the first term.
And this right here reveals the
Direct Line of causation in the
argument.
The failure to be decisive in
the first term, the author
argues, is what allowed the rot
to spread, to metastasize.
And that's why this radical
amputation is now presented as
the only option left.
And so this explainer leaves us
with a final, really provocative
question.
This entire doctrine is focused
on the act of removal, of
cutting something out, and it
forces us to consider the
aftermath after the surgery is
done, what comes next, what's
built in the space that's been
cleared.